my guest this week is the award-winning
Nigerian writer and author chimamande
nagosi adichie named by Time Magazine as
one of its most influential people her
writing covers everything from war to
feminism to most recently a very
personal take on Grief having lost both
of her parents in quick succession
to ask her a being described as Fearless
for speaking her mind and also what it
was like to team up with Beyonce to try
and promote feminism
[Music]
welcome it's so lovely to have you with
me on this program and uh and see you in
person I know thank you Emma for having
me it's lovely to see you well the last
time we spoke it was last year yeah and
you had just penned a short book called
notes on Grief and we were talking in a
difficult time for you um but you wanted
a talk about losing your father and then
losing your mother and you said to me
you were trying to understand grief and
and process it and I wonder I wanted to
start by asking how you are today well
I think I'm learning that a lot of
living is sort of pretending to be fine
so I'm I think I'm doing that very well
yeah I'm fine I'm fine thank you for
asking but I you know I think
everything happy that happens to me now
is always tainted by a kind of um sort
of like a residual sadness
and it's because I just adored my
parents and it still feels very very
disorienting for me
about yeah I mean you talked about those
stages as well you know Coming Undone
feeling unmoored but you're right about
the world expects you to get back yeah
to some place and you have your
responsibilities as well and you do you
just sort of you know you but you carry
something with you always and I it's
interesting because I thought that I
would be more aware of this this kind of
emptiness in my life when I'm sad but
actually it's when I'm happy
it's when I'm having a lovely day and
suddenly I think my God I can't I can't
you know I can't FaceTime Daddy and I I
had a thing in the U.S last month where
I got a lovely medal and I love those
things because I just love shiny things
and all I could I really I really did
want to take my phone and FaceTime my
parents because that's what I've done my
whole life when I've been given
something meaningful you know it's to
call my parents well they're the people
who you know who cheer you up yeah so
really I mean I really I really was
going to FaceTime them until wait I
can't it's those moments that I really
just painful something else you said
which has stayed with me is the idea
that we live in this world
and we know death's a part of it and
we're still so surprised
it's incredible and even when we see as
I do now life is short you really need
to think about what matters and how you
want to live
it's it's also at the same time a
strange thing to live life always
thinking about death
because in a way death is sort of the
you know it's the on life it's the it's
the not life and so it's a strange thing
I think I mean I do want to I and I
think a lot changed for me when my
parents died
in the way that I think about life and
how I want to live
but I think death is still surprising
it still is one of the ways I mean I
don't know how much this speaks to you
but people talk about faith and that
helping them through these sorts of
times do you have that in your life have
you come back to that
it's very complicated
after my father died I started I was
raised Catholic you know some Catholic
well Greece Catholic there's a
difference I think for me between being
Catholic and being raised Catholic
um one one doesn't have a choice in one
the other you kind of have a choice
and I started going to mass because I
found that it I found I found it
soothing
but particularly because it was what my
father did my father was just you know
this lovely faithful Catholic but then I
started I had trouble with the Catholic
church in Nigeria
and I was so angry
that I stopped going
and it's a long story but I'll just say
very briefly that when my mother died at
my mother's funeral a priest
um
sort of use the opportunity of my
mother's funeral to attack me about an
interview I had given
and so you know imagine just sitting
there is being completely lost because
you still do not understand what
happened you know your mother is gone
and my mother died so suddenly and and
the priest at her funeral sort of takes
the microphone and says you know
chimamanda was attacking the church
because she says the church is too
obsessed with money which they are which
I said but at my mother's funeral
so that made me so angry and I I haven't
been back since I mean did you say
anything at the time oh I did that's you
know I got up and I said you know you I
need to speak because you cannot do this
um and I then sort of I did spend a lot
of time sort of seeking redress writing
to Bishops and nothing
I think how religious institutions use
their power over individuals but also
how it intersects with politics is in
people's minds especially in America at
the moment since Roe v Wade with the
overturning of that of that ruling and I
and I wanted to ask you about it because
we see in Christianity with Christianity
it being used by politicians by
legislators yeah to defend the rowing
back of of those particular rights for
women and you of course are very well
known for speaking out about feminism
and the rights of women you know someone
raised Catholic how do you look at that
and that situation
well the first thing I think is that one
should never impose one's religious
views on on anyone in a democracy and
I've often felt quite respectful of
those people who for religious reasons
do not support or want to have abortions
I think that's fantastic for them
right but to somehow insist that a woman
doesn't have a right to do what she
wants with her body and to and to then
justify that using religion I think it's
just completely unacceptable for a
democracy just it makes no sense to me
I mean for me being Catholic doesn't
mean instead of agreeing with everything
even when I was a child growing up I was
a bit of a I think at Catholicism
classes I think that they were irritated
with me because I would sort of poke
holes at the
um some of the things that we were being
taught if collectively as a society we
really believe that women are equal we
would not be having this conversation if
you step back and think about it it's
actually almost surreal
um to say your body doesn't belong to
you
it's a very strange thing I think a lot
of people describe you as Fearless now
you know in this age that we live in uh
where social media was meant to liberate
us and allow us to share it has
imprisoned us and there's a real concern
in particular that that women are being
pushed out of the Public Square not
saying what they really think
do you have that concern
for myself new for women yes
um
you know when I'm called Fearless I
I guess it's nice but I I do I
I don't really think of myself as
Fearless
I've always this is what I've always
been really I think part of the reason
I'm so fiercely feminist about the way I
look at the world is that I knew from a
very young age that to be a girl
and to be as I was with your sort of you
know outspoken asking questions was kind
of seen as odd so even now I think is
you know sort of an ostensibly
full-grown woman to be told um you
really see what you think it's a thing
that's a compliment for women not for
men
but but I think we're also living in
times where to to say what you think yes
that's true has also become yeah
something that people are called
Fearless yes yes that's true again to
use your word from earlier has a
surrealism yeah to it yeah
um yeah I know it's only one platform
but it is the platform a lot of the time
of debate in terms of social media with
Twitter now being run by Elon Musk some
people men and women have left the
platform in protest equally others are
saying now there will be or could be
real freedom of speech do you have a
view on that
I don't think one person should be in
control of a platform that has that kind
of outsize
um
social influence
I just don't think I just don't think it
makes sense and you know people can say
oh well we bought it it's his or before
they would say oh they're just really
beholden to only their shareholders but
I I think it's a public utility it
should be we should think of it as a
public utility so it really shouldn't be
one person this is the way we live now
sadly and we have to figure out a way to
I'm going to sound like a a preacher we
need to do better
but I really think we do I don't think
we can change
I think we can change how we use the
platforms I really detest this kind of
piling on that happens when people have
said something that somebody doesn't
like
and you know it's not just that you
criticize them it's that you
you publicize their address you put
their children's schools online that
sort of thing and we try to get them to
lose their jobs I've just never felt
that that is in any way a reasonable
response to to bad speech right but I
also sometimes wonder why there isn't
mod more that's done to
the those who pile on people
so you know so often we'll say oh that's
terrible
but that's it I'm not on Twitter but I
think if I were and there's a reason I'm
not it just would not go well because I
think I would go after the people who
pile on people and be like you just
you're just a piece of
and you need to stop I mean you have had
people even though you're not on that
platform be very upset about various
things that you've said and has that
affected you
yes and no
I think so in general I think this idea
that we're supposed to say that we're
fine when you hear that the tons of
people maligning you publicly
to say that I'm fine it would be to lie
and and I think it's either you're lying
or you're a narcissist because how can
you not how can you not be affected by
it and so when I first the first time
that I had older saying that you're
terrible and that you're a murderer
I was just deeply hurt I was deeply
deeply hurt what was that after was that
after something you'd say yes okay yeah
um well surely I mean I didn't kill
anyone yeah no I was just yeah that's
such a check in interviews
there are some people I would like to
kill no I'm kidding I'm kidding
um
so it was very hurtful but
but it won't make me change
it will not make me change how I live my
life
it hasn't and it won't I'm still going
to say what I think so you don't you
haven't self-censored
because that's the the real risk here
isn't it when we get into this position
because I did notice you have not wanted
to answer questions about when you said
in an interview for instance trans women
are women and not necessarily to go into
that issue per se but I wonder why you
haven't wanted to talk about
no what I haven't wanted to do is say
more
but I've said I've said what I said and
that's what I think
why not say more because of the reaction
well because it's been said I just think
yeah because I just think also that this
is the sort of this age of of
[Music]
um
you know like a friend of mine said you
said what you said anybody asking you
more about this is just trying to sort
of stoke outrage and make it more of a
thing and which was never my intention
right I
I said what I said it's what I believe
it's what I still believe
but then having people say to me you
know tell me more tell me more I'm just
like No And also you know I have a full
life there are many many things I'm
interested in and yeah
I suppose I mean when people have
thought about that particular issue and
gender and sex
there's a lot of talk now about JK
Rowling yeah and how she's continued to
share views and and be very alive on
platforms such as Twitter to this
particular topic but there's now a bit
more of people in the public eye who've
worked with her coming forward to say
exactly about freedom of speech that why
has she been treated in this way why has
there been this and I wonder if things
are
changing or turning I don't know what
your take is I don't know if you ever
spoken to her about no no no I haven't
spoken to her but um
I read so when when I started reading
about how she was being attacked I then
went and read what she'd written which I
thought was perfectly reasonable and I
did not see why she needed to be
attacked and I think that she's been
treated abominably
and I think a lot of that treatment is
because she's a woman
I think that a man who aired his views
reasonable views
um would not be treated in that way
and there is also something I think very
dangerous about refusing to engage with
what she said
but instead making it and sort of sort
of hurling insults
um when I read how I remember reading
what she'd written and underlining bits
because of the essay on sex and gender
yeah underlining bits of it because some
young people in Lagos I said oh she's
terrible she's transphobic she wants to
kill trans people and and so I said to
them where does it see that here and I
don't even in a literal sense because
there are ways that you can read
something to mean something else but but
none of them could point point it out to
me and I suppose this goes to one of the
essays you wrote uh called it's obscene
you talk about cancer culture and lots
of other things in there but you do
Express this concern at this particular
quote you say we have a generation of
young people on social media so
terrified of having the wrong opinions
that they've robbed themselves of the
opportunity to think and to learn and to
grow yep
you talk to young people you lecture
them I saw recently you told them to get
offline for three weeks and read some
books yeah
it's a serious issue and I know you're
probably thinking about it as well as a
parent what can we do about this we can
try being adults you know we I sometimes
feel as though we have abdicated our
responsibility as the grown-ups because
I know what it was like to be young I
thought I knew everything
now I look back I'm like I just did I
knew nothing you know I was wrong in
many of my sort of fierce positions
and I was fortunate that when I was
young there were adults were willing to
tell me you're actually really not right
about that here's what you should think
about differently that's not happening
now
um we're also not saying to young people
you cannot I mean
so I remember talking to um students at
a university in the U.S and it really
made me sad because
until well first of all we meet and we
sort of talk I'm asking them questions
and they're really
it felt as though they were repeating
party lines in a way about just general
issues I think it's tough for them
and I just you know so I sort of did a
little preaching and I said you know
can we all agree on compassion
um can we all agree that you know not
everyone means harm
can we all agree that people can learn
and people change you know just to sort
of basic things that
we seem to have forgotten I think you
know
there are lots of things I don't know I
mean the things that I I don't
understand I mean and again not to go
back to the famous trans woman is a
trans woman
I thought I was saying something obvious
I did not mean to offend anyone and but
later I thought wait a minute what have
I missed things I don't understand so I
went back and I started reading things
because I just thought I I really didn't
understand what the
noise was about and so I think about
young people and I think I'm sure there
are many people in my position which is
to say do not know the Orthodoxy right
and who should be giving a chance to
know it and then choose whether to
accept it or reject it
I don't think that they're giving that
chance yeah well and and also they don't
feel they have the space necessarily to
to have those conversations a lot of
people want to hear I suppose where your
your feminism is up to and I and I
wonder because feminism in that time is
less of a dirty word certainly in in the
western world it's being sold as a brand
it's by fashion by the media and I but I
wonder if it has achieved what it's
meant to have achieved yet
no of course not it's not going to
achieve it in the next 100 years
it took a long time for us to get here I
mean we've had
um
really human history the sort of the
length of time that we've been here on
Earth
we've had men instead of being in charge
and if we're going to achieve equality
it's going to take a long time so that
it doesn't I think for Me Maybe the
question I would be interested in is are
we taking a few steps forward but at the
same time we're we're seeing marching
we're seeing protests and you know since
the death of Martha amini in Iran who
was held by Iran's morality police for
not covering her hair properly she died
on the 16th of September those protests
are carrying on led by women in Iran and
and also in Afghanistan women trying to
go back to University all their jobs
since the Taliban took over it was very
striking there's a footage going of a
woman being a few women being whipped by
Taliban I saw that this morning outside
of University but chanting women life
Freedom which is the same words chosen
by women in Iran and while it's awful
what's being denied there's also
something in what's being said oh I find
it enormously inspiring I think that
they are just absolute Stars I mean
there's particularly the women in Iran
and Afghanistan because you think about
what the what they're standing up
against
um and I felt that that that whipping
video is such a dramatic
um sort of example of
of what their lives are like but they're
still pushing back I just find it so
inspiring and the women in Iran when
they're cutting their hair and they're
throwing the thing in the fire eye
actually was weeping watching one of
them it was incredibly emotional and
also
it's happening now yeah you know now get
your head around that as well I always
wondered if you found it frustrating
that some came to your work through
Beyonce as opposed to finding you
themselves
you know I mean I
no I'll tell you one of the things one
of the reasons that I wasn't I was happy
to do you know happy to say yes this is
because she just to say if people don't
know she she took some of your words
sampled some of your words for a song
yes it's because I thought that she has
such a huge following that they're going
to be people who never heard the word
feminism
never thought about it who will because
of this and for me that's a wonderful
thing but to help people come to my
readings and say oh I never heard about
you then then I then I heard you on
Beyonce and then they don't want to ask
me anything about my books they want to
ask me so Beyonce that doesn't interest
me
that's that's not the way this is gonna
work no but I think also there's a part
of me that just I feel this way about
films as well when people say oh it's
fantastic your book was made into a film
and I'm thinking it's nice but I wrote
the bloody book I want to talk about
books I want books to be cool I won't be
excited about books you know and we're
just not and it just you know I just
feel deeply deeply annoyed by that but
it's you know whether we have the wrong
Heroes and you know how we look at the
world yeah I do I I agree and also want
those the responsibility that those
Heroes Have and I'm I'm wary of talking
about this because I do not like people
telling me you're a role model therefore
you should not do this but I think for
example that Beyonce making the the
decision
um and people can think what they will
about talking about feminism I think
it's a really good thing because and I
know for a fact that there are many
young people who because of that
suddenly I mean I know relatives young
nieces who you know Auntie talks about
feminism Auntie writes books Beyonce
talks about families they're like I'm a
feminist and now they're making what
they think are feminist arguments and I
think it's fantastic because you know
conversations are happening it's good to
hear that Beyonce help you get closer to
your family
no among a certain sort of cohort
they suddenly thought Auntie's not too
bad okay yeah it's just you know we can
yeah she's tolerable now what are you
working on now I cannot tell you you
can't tell me you don't like saying it
do you until it's not okay but writing I
imagine or okay the creativity though
has it come back since your daughter is
it coming it's slowly coming back but I
think again that's amazing for women in
particular to be able to hear you say
that because again it's not something
that's talked about long after effects
yes yes I think it's really important to
talk about and also to talk about it
knowing that we love that we we had the
gift of motherhood and and babies and we
adore them a gift it is so it really is
it really is
but you know we should talk about the
other things because nobody told me
about the I mean I had horrible joint
pains in my fingers
um you know and and nobody told me about
the constipation and I just feel like we
need to talk about these things and you
laugh at when I say constipation which
apparently is the puzzling response I
get from other people as well no we
should talk about I I personally was
shocked
and I was like what's happening and my
husband my husband is a doctor and he
was sort of oh you didn't know and I
wanted to punch his face I was like of
course I didn't know those two types of
constipation it was the literal and the
creative so we've covered both I like
that
thank you very much for talking to me
and to all of us today it's been a
pleasure and memorable as always thank
you and thank you so much for being with
us until we meet again take care and
goodbye
foreign
[Applause]
[Music]